في تقرير من القدس قالت صحيفه لوموند ان
غزه تحت القصف اصبحت مهدده
[موسيقى]
بالمجاعة على الاطلاق لتغطيه الاحتياجات
الاساسيه
للسكان تطرقت الكاتبه الين جاكوت في
مقالها بصحيفه لوتون الى تركيز مجلس الامن
على تقديم المساعدات لغزه دون الدعوه الى
هدنه عاجله وتابعت ان ما يفسر غياب
الادانه في الوقت الذي اجتاحت فيه المجاعه
غزه واسفرت الضربات الاسرائيليه عن مقتل
اكثر من 20 ال شخص هو بالطبع دعم واشنطن
لاسرائيل ولكن الكاتبه تقترح سببا اخر
وراء موقف الامم المتحده وهو الرغبه في
السماح للاطراف المتحاربه بابرام هدنه
بانفسهم وهو ما قد يكون اكثر فعاليه من نص
الامم المتحده اجرت صحيفه الواشنطن بوست
تحليلا معمقا لصور الاقمار الصناعيه
وبيانات الغارات الجويه وتقييمات الامم
المتحده للاضرار في غزه واجرت مقابلات مع
اكثر من 20 من عمال الاغاثه وخب الحرب
واظهرت الادله ان اسرائيل شنت حربها في
غزه بوتيره ومستوى من الدمار يتجاوز اي
صراع حديث في القرن الحادي
والعشرين قال الصحفي الاسرائيلي بن درور
يميني في مقاله بصحيفه يديعوت احرونوت لا
احد مثل نتنياهو تحدث عن التهديد النووي
الايراني وكلما تحدث اكثر صارت ايران اقوى
لا احد تحدث اكثر من نتنياهو عن خطر
الارهاب ولم يكن الارهاب اكثر خطرا منه
خلال حكمه لا احد يتحدث عن الصمود الوطني
اكثر من نتنياهو ولا احد اضر به اكثر منه
لا احد تسبب في تدهور مكانه اسرائيل في
العالم والولايات المتحده اكثر من نتنياهو
ويرى الكاتب ان الوقت قد حان كي يرحل
نتنياهو وتسلك اسرائيل طريقا جديدا نختم
من صحيفه الفاينانشال تايمز حيث كتبت
بولينا ايفانوفا عن الغاء الاحتفالات بعيد
الميلاد لاول مره في بيت لحم مسقط راس
السيد المسيح مع احتدام الحرب في غزه
وتابعت الكاتبه انه بالنسبه لسكان بيت لحم
فان الموت والدمار على بعد 70 كت فقط في
غزه يجعل احتفالات عيد الميلاد المعتاده
في غير محلها بل ان المدينه تعيش حاله
حداد على الخسائر البشريه الناجمه عن
الهجوم الاسرائيلي على غزه y